welcome to this video playing all of our
fee and sis Qatar what is this Katara
right ok and one game against him which
I didn't lose and ok it was a good way
to lose another pre moving Bishop g5 ok
I'm a 3 is designed to prevent Bishop
reform so how do we play this now should
be three on ship d3 Bishop e3 problem
KD 5 snot and working yet so let's play
centralizing moves
hmm it's also be five as an idea but
generally you want to push the deeper in
this kind of positions and a 5mm
might be three maybe this is an idea
yeah I can still try t5 simply open it
up yeah I really not sure and I don't
have much experience with this kind of
position actually sometimes arises from
the patrols in the system of the Queen's
Indian was some semi tirage which both
every never had on the board i think
almost never
so each form is quite often useful in
this kind of position gaining some space
and allowing 95
ok
so h5 or not not sure if this move
really really helps that 'if I've is
also interesting for possible 94 let's
do that and maybe Queen h5
we should each for Queen h5 looks more
than dangerous really and if I've also
makes sure night c4 is not coming
amazing okay so Queen age five I guess
through the e5 and destruction on h6
White Knight f6 first of course it's
also pretty substantial so now Bishop
age six or some kind of Defense 5 25
just not not help I can also take on age
6 let's check and then five that's
actually pretty convincing know when is
God Bishop g5
hmm
push-up h6 GTX if five doesn't that win
then five
I look a little bit like everything
winds but those situations are dangerous
here you go g6e or something and survive
that would be sick really sick my beam
hmm unbelievable that's really really
not not so clear I mean
come on please I really want to win this
game I mean not winning this is
basically saying okay my opponents can
do everything and suits wife because I'm
simply not refuting their nonsense and
this is just amazing so night I have six
wins the Queen but does it win the game
if i take f8 time morning jack I'm going
to take the take the material here
Bishop I have six take this Bishop g6
queen is six and look at his server I
could be maybe that's a bit much
40-something second sighs kind of its
not coordinated so badly
I should going to see for am
hg5 is a serious threat and takes and
then g5 okay good defense
I should have gotten Bishop f5 them and
we've been a bit better yeah keep the
just cutting the roof off
check I could have taken this rise by
any way of seven hangs check Pina six
maids coming check check
six seconds left amazing check their
should shift on the C file check check
check check stalemate yeah come on add
to pre move at the pre move no nope
never can do I had to premium couldn't
be six of course was checking Stanley
yeah yeah what a sick game I mean I
really really really really want to know
how you can take on h4 in this position
so here between d8 sick part is that ok
well I don't trust the comp am it it's
just on depth 20 give it more depth and
it will find a win that's really
impossible not to be a winning position
with wide attacking with everything so
this is actually not winning at least
not immediately so the engine actually
wants to go d5
hmm
yeah okay that g6 move really this is
clear that this g6 is kind of yeah it's
not even the best defense well yeah I'm
okay the engine on depth 20 something is
not really 2324 it's not really reliable
him it needs to sometimes calculate a
little bit deeper to see what it really
is we know not this is of course also
interesting
it's funny that then the engine actually
think that black can survive this check
and then f5 supposed to be no no it
gives a win for White Queen g6 and
Bishop f4 it's not so clear I mean of
course the computer can give a reliable
assessment of this this kind of super
concrete position but you sometimes
really still have to calculate it for a
while so it's really not not quite clear
if white if why the check is winning
here or not even moves like I mean now
the computers is coming to look be one
maybe sometimes going to be five it's
really hard to say without letting it
calculate for longer for longer while
okay I want to check this a little bit
gtex it's actually playable according to
the computer I just thought if Ivan
curtains no it's not Curtis this seems
to hold check and now King g7 okay there
that move I didn't see no black actually
holds him he really holds this okay that
makes my idea here makena engine
actually wants to look a three year and
says equal which is kind of a puzzling
check check King g7 should be one for
Luke g3 assessment equal and this this
this loses it seems with exactly the
line here k and Bishop g6 does win yeah
I had this hunch that it might win but I
couldn't really bring myself to give
back material because I couldn't
calculate this fully check check ok so
here whoop t7 is winning ok and here
would be second this leads to a system
some made ok ok so he actually has to go
here and now i can take it take andrew
t-7s dismayed yeah okay so that that was
winning I mean I saw the move but I
really felt ok let's let's keep ya
Bishop 26 again wins I just felt like
okay keep the material and try to win
with the material i blundered that and
now I'm really winning yeah ok anyway it
was a corset time issue at the end there
was like three Queens aboard ok thanks
for watching